as per my last video a cube that shifts
perspective between its mirror image and
back can help us to see rotations
through the fourth dimension this is eye
patch MC12 Edge his true self has an eye
patch on his right eye right now you are
inside of his hollowed out head looking
out through his eyes that are facing
towards me I look at the side reminds
you of that fact but if you concentrate
you can mentally pull out the center of
his head until the cube is facing
outwards looking towards you in that
version of him mig-12 Edge has his eye
patch on his left eye in this 3D World
there is no way that I could ever rotate
the real Mick 12 inch to have his eye
patch on his left eye the version that
your mind was seeing has been rotated
around a line in a higher Dimension
you're now thinking in 4D